[Musica]
i ragazzi per essere qua io sono molto
contento di tornare a leggermi avevo
qualche anno e allora vi parlerò di
questa cosa qua appunto di questa
sostituzione in atto e se web e robot
show con il lavoro
forse ci comprerà puntare sulle cose che
ci rendono umani
cominciamo dalla fine e la fine è questo
signori qua un signore diciamo avete
imparato a conoscerlo con questo sorriso
a 24 carati e il caso il caso di dirlo
il motivo perchè lui è dove adesso è un
motivo è noto è questo qua ci crede che
questa curva dei posti nella manifattura
negli stati uniti è una brutta curva
gravemente verso il basso ma questa è
una parte nota diciamolo sappiamo lui ha
promesso di rendere di nuovo l'america
grande riportando quei lavori la parte
che non sapeva amare questa qui che più
interessante pino vai a che fare col
discorso che stiamo facendo
ovvero a sinistra vedete la mappa
elettorale di trump gli stati in cui ha
vinto più a mani basse che coincide in
maniera stupefacente con la cospicua
eccezione della california con l'altra
mappa quella di destra azzurrina sono
gli stati in cui la professione più
prevalente è il autista di camion che
cosa c'entrano queste due cose c'entrano
perché gli autisti di camion era
praticamente una delle poche professioni
della classe media che non richiedeva un
alto titolo di studio però era
considerata sicura perché non era stata
intaccata dalla delocalizzazione cioè
per guidare un camion
ci volevano essere umano non in messico
non in cina ma li nell'ohio nel
wisconsin e così via
questo era prima però perché adesso non
sarà più vero perché stiamo parlando
appunto di 3,5 milioni di persone che
con l'indotto diventano 5,2 milioni di
persone
questi numeri a questo punto sarebbero
presi andati in fiamme ma questa è
un'altra squalifica di un software
quando il software trascodifica il
lavoro della sua mano questo è l'effetto
ma insomma il senso è che questi lavori
spariscono e questi lavori spariscono
più alla svelta di quanto pensavamo
perché questa è una stima di morgan
stanley
che di solito ci si prende con le stime
di giovani indice 2022 2023 vedete qua
quando la safety naveen cardi tra una
cosa una cosa diffusa
peccato che in questa circostanza questo
futuro questo futuro è già arrivato è
arrivato il 15 settembre di quest'anno
qualche mese fa a pittsburgh sono
arrivate le prime la prima flottiglia di
auto di huber senza pilota cioè voi
prendete la vostra app chiamata una
macchina ne avete una buona chance che
via di una macchina totalmente in grado
di guidarsi da sola ora per competenza e
per l'onestà dico che dietro al volante
c'è un essere umano che interviene solo
in caso di in caso di necessità però sta
dando maggior parte del tempo con le
braccia conserte se tutto va bene
diciamo non fa niente perché l'acqua
l'auto si guida da sola ora noi
soprattutto noi giornalisti abbiamo una
grande responsabilità in questo perché
parliamo tantissimo della macchina che
si guida da sola e parliamo poco del
camion che seguita da solo una
tecnologia
ovviamente è la stessa e le conseguenze
un mercato e lavoro sono molto più
rilevanti e allora io vi farò vedere
adesso 10 i numeri una specie
internamente arredi elettrico si è
incontrato qualcuno particolarmente
ottimista sul futuro del lavoro al bar
avrete diciamo dei buoni argomenti da da
opporgli e il 10 argomenti sono chi sono
questi qua sono dieci nome ci avete
gesti che pubblicano specie ossessione
sui 10 numeri e non faccio eccezione
allora il primo numero è 2000 che in
verità è una data e una data in cui
succede qualcosa di strano vedete questi
due curve sono sopra e la curva della
produttività e sotto la curva
dell'occupazione queste curva vanno dal
dopoguerra in poi
abbastanza di concerto dico abbastanza
un po si discostano ma c'è un punto in
cui cominciano a flettere a divaricarsi
queste due ricercatori delle menti che
hanno fatto questo studio si chiamano
eric brin jolson andrew mcafee parlano
di grande disaccoppiamento e questo
grande disaccoppiamento comincia a farsi
vedere in maniera più forte intorno
all'anno 2000 perché perché 2000 è
l'anno in cui l'economia internettiana
comincia a girare dicevano veramente
pieni a pieno regime ed intermediando ma
soprattutto perché le macchine per tutta
una serie di novità si chiamano machine
learning big data gestione di data
cominciano ad andare troppo forte per
gli uomini cioè io mi non riescono più a
tenere il passo e la crescita dei posti
di lavoro si ferma
secondo numero numero 47 è un altro
studio che è diventato un classico è una
percentuale di questa volta 47 per cento
e a che fare con questa cosa qua due
ricercatori questa volta di oxford si
chiamano carlo frey e michael osbourne e
hanno calcolato la probabilità il
rischio che da qui a vent'anni e una
qualcosa nel 2013 quindi la data finale
al 2033
e quante occupazioni di quelle esistenti
adesso nel mercato americano sono a
rischio di automazione non dico che
saranno sostituite ma ci sarà la
tecnologia per sostituirle il 47 per
cento sono altre rischio vedere voi di
qua non so dove mettermi nei sommersi e
salvati insomma metà di questa sala è ad
alto rischio di automazione forse voi ci
penserei
il terzo numero il terzo numero è questo
qua e 5 per un numero grosso però
nonostante che sta che sono questa è la
previsione di del world economic forum
di davos dell'anno scorso di un di un
panel di economisti che hanno che hanno
intercettato per capire quale sarà il
saldo fra posti nuovi creati e posti
distrutte alla tecnologia
da qui al 2020 questo è il loro
risultato c'è anche un altro risultato
di mackenzie che è una probabilmente
dall'agenzia di consulenza più grande
del mondo più famose nel mondo che nel
2025 25 anni dopo calcio la questo salto
in 7 milioni in meno diciamo compreso
appunto quelli creati e quelli distrutti
c'è anche un altro numero potrei andare
avanti a lungo ma il tempo è tiranno 15
milioni
andrew haldane chief economist della
banca d'inghilterra la pensa ancora
ancora peggio quello che mi interessa
che che abbiamo ben chiaro che davanti a
questi numeri piuttosto grossi c'è
sempre un segno
meno è il quarto numero il quarto numero
è 15
questa volta stiamo parlando di questa
cosa qua forse l'avete visto da qualche
parte questo è un magazzino di amazon e
qui sotto sono dei muletti si chiamano
chi fa sono dei robot che funzionano
benissimo peccato che grazie anche a
questi monetti amazon per generare 10
milioni di dollari di fatturato impiega
15 persone mentre un negozio
tradizionale e impiegava anche compresa
la grande distribuzione
ne occupava impiegava 47 che come sapete
più di tre volte tanto e questo è solo
l'inizio perché quelle macchinette lì
sono sempre più brave e ne soffriranno
ancora di più
siamo al quinto numero il quinto numero
e a che fare con questa cosa qua che
tutti voi o quasi tutti voi conoscerete
si chiama instagram è un'applicazione
per condividere le immagini quando è
stata comprata da facebook per un
miliardo di dollari nel 2012 aveva 13
dipendenti 13 dipendenti
per fare un paragone kodak che assolveva
la stessa funzione sociale ovvero
condividere immagini con le persone che
ci sono care aveva il suo momento alto
140.000 dipendenti con ironia della
sorte è fallita dell'anno prima
instagram fosse comprata da facebook e
siamo al sesto numero numero gand e
stavolta 160 mila e hanno a che fare con
questo signore qual che forse non
conoscete ma riconoscere senz'altro crea
prete che si può dire senza diciamo
rischio di iperbole una stanza geniale
si chiama andrew angie ex professore a
stanford poi affondato con una collega
una piattaforma che si chiama corsera
dove si possono seguire dei corsi on
line di tanto in velocità anche molto
prestigiose praticamente gratuitamente
con pochi o con poche decine di dollari
bene a un certo punto il suo corso
il suo corso e stato di intelligenza
artificiale è stato seguito da 160 mila
studenti in tutto il mondo chi da reggio
emilia chi da seattle a chi dalla cina e
così via
dove dov'è il problema nessuna parte se
non che come scenario possiamo fare un
esperimento mentale
ora sono state 160 mila non potevano
essere un milione 6 basta allargare la
banda diciamo del serve che lo era
o potrebbero essere 16 milioni di
studenti di andrew g e siccome è
veramente molto fico
perché uno dovrebbe andare dal secondo
piu figo del mondo dal terzo visto che
possiamo avere accesso al g va tutto
bene se non che questo è uno scenario
che economisti come conoscono bene si
chiama se cioè il vincitore prende tutto
la domanda è cosa faranno tutti gli
altri insegnanti che non sono così fichi
come andrew m g le fotocopie punto di
domanda
settimo numero settimo numero questa
volta e 500 e ci porta più vicino a noi
anzi decisamente più vicino a casa mia a
roma questa stazione termini 500 è il
numero di biglietti che queste
macchinette fanno al giorno in media 500
biglietti contro i 200 biglietti che fa
uno sportellista umano e che ha altri
svantaggi tipici peculiari degli esseri
umani fanno una pausa più fanno la pausa
pranzo hanno bisogno dei ticket
restaurant e perché insomma
e così via e costano una frazione di
stromae costano purtroppo molto di più
delle macchine secondo voi nel futuro a
breve diciamo vedrete più sportellisti
umani o più macchinette automatiche
accetto scommesse allora il numero 860
mila 60.000 santa mina è esattamente la
popolazione della città dove sono nato
io viareggio ecco immaginate uno
scenario in cui il da un giorno
all'altro viareggio
diciamo in casa come popolazione
lavorativa sparisce e quella che è
successo a questi questi signori qua che
lavorano per un'azienda che tutti voi
con cui tutti voi avete un po a che fare
perché diciamo e quelle che costruisce
vostri iphone il mio iphone i vostri di
samsung i vostri televisori lg qualsiasi
cosa che potrei pensare di elettronica
di consumo praticamente foxton la
produce e fox con in un colpo solo ha
fatto fuori il 60 mila dipendenti perché
ha assunto al loro posto altrettanti
robot
d'altronde l'amministrazione delegato
qualche anno fa lo aveva annunciato
assumerò avrà detto e si fa per dire
diciamo un milione di robot e così sta
facendo piano piano piano piano anche
questo si fa per dire
siamo al nono numero è il nono numero è
questo 2000 come quello prima ma questa
non è una data che un altro numero
è una cifra e sono duemila immagini è
triste ma la vita è fatta anche di
queste cose come questa è un anestesista
macchina in fondo che vede sulla
sinistra una macchina che fa johnson and
johnson
insomma questa macchina invece di
costare 2.000 dollari come costava
diciamo con con lo specialista in sede
con la macchina fare un'anestesia basta
mettere un sondino e costa 200 dollari
200 dollari
decimo numero e questo perché
tipicamente a questo punto c'è qualcuno
che mi dice ma tu sei troppo pessimista
tu non calcoli quanti nuovi lavori
fantastici ci saranno creati tu non
riesci neanche a immaginarti benissimo
c'è qualcuno che questo sforzo di
immaginazione ha fatto eco il car frey
di oxford che vi citavo prima
quant'è la percentuale di americani di
manodopera americana che oggi lavora le
aziende nate dopo il 2000 no presenti
tutti quelli di cui abbiamo parlato lo
zero aveva 5 per cento
avete capito bene 0,5 per cento quelle
aziende di cui parliamo tantissimo danno
da lavorare a lo 0,5 per cento
via d'uscita a la politica tasse webcast
se ne parla in questi giorni padova ne
sta parlando
parliamone sul serio perché apple paga
lo 0,005 per cento di tasse in irlanda e
perché google paga 300 milioni di tasti
in italia ma ne doveva 900 milioni
quindi non capisco cosa c'è da
festeggiare
amazon è sotto scacco della guardia di
finanza per gli stessi motivi si può
parlare se tutto questo non funzionasse
anche di redditi si rialza ma sul serio
non in maniera diciamo strumentale la
cultura questa è la sala borsa a bologna
l'empatia la cura la capacità di
risolvere problemi imprevisti
emozionarsi il fare emozionale tutte le
cose qui gli umani sono molto ancora
brava di bellezza e creatività
ovviamente ovvero le cose per cui vale
la pena vivere
io direi
il vecchio groucho marx un gioco di
maggio secondo movimento della sinfonia
jupiter lui a mostro l'incisione di
potere the blues si svedese naturalmente
l'educazione sentimentale di flaubert
marlon brando frank sinatra quelle
incredibili mele pere dipinte da cézanne
è granché da sam in attesa dei pressi
ecco il viso di trani su tutte queste
cose qua sono ancora fortunatamente
insostituibili buon futuro a tutti
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]